.
>>> I AGREE WITH BOTH OF YOU.
VERY COURAGEOUS ON TONY'S PART.
GREAT INTERVIEW.
>>> TONIGHT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS OBSESSED WITH
RACIAL INEQUALITY.
, KAMALA HARRIS REMAINS LOCKED
INTO HER BELIEF THAT PEOPLE OF
COVER SHOULD RECEIVE FLORIDA
HURRICANE RELIEF FUNDING FIRST.
KANYE WEST MEANWHILE IS CALLING
BLACK LIVES MATTER A SCAM.
ONE PROMINENT DEMOCRAT IS NOW
RE-UPPING HER CALLS TO DEFUND
AND DISMANTLE THE POLICE.
BUT FIRST TONIGHT, WE ONLY HAVE
A WHOPPING 35 DAYS UNTIL THE ALL
IMPORTANT MIDTERMS AND VIAL
PERSONAL ATTACKS FROM THE LEFT
ARE REACHING A FEVER PITCH.
THEY CANNOT RUN ON THEIR RECORD
WITH ABSOLUTELY NOTHING POSITIVE
TO RUN ON.
DEMOCRATS ARE NOW ATTEMPTING TO
DEHUMANIZE REPUBLICANS ALL
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND SET A
GUBERNATORIAL RACES.
THEY DO SO FROM A GLASS HOUSE.
TONIGHT WE WILL EXPOSE TWO
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES FOR SENATE
WHO DO NOT DESERVE THE VOTE IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE STATES.
WE BEGAN IN THE GREAT STATE OF
GEORGIA TONIGHT.
WHILE THE MEDIA MOB IS OBSESSING
OVER ANONYMOUS SOURCES AND THE
NEW YORK TIMES REGURGITATED BY
OTHER MEDIA AND FIXATED ON
FAMILY DRAMA SURROUNDING
REPUBLICAN HERSCHEL WALKER.
THEY HAVE BEEN MORE THAN HAPPY
TO IGNORE VERY SERIOUS
ALLEGATIONS AGAINST THE DEMOCRAT
SENATOR RAFAEL WARNOCK.
WARNOCK WAS ORDERED BY A
SUPERIOR COURT JUDGE TO ATTEND
MEDIATION AFTER HE WAS ACCUSED
OF NEGLECTING HIS OWN CHILDREN,
FAILING TO PAY CHILD CARE
EXPENSES DESPITE AMASSING A NET
WORTH OF NEARLY A MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN 2020 WARNOCK WAS ALSO ACCUSED
OF HITTING HIS EX-WIFE WITH A
CAR DURING AN ALTERCATION.
HERE IS HIS EX-WIFE TALKING TO
POLICE AFTER THE INCIDENT.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THIS MAN IS RUNNING FOR THE
UNITED STATES SENATE AND ALL HE
CARES ABOUT IS HIS REPUTATION.
I WORK AT THE MAYOR'S OFFICE AND
THIS IS A BIG PROBLEM.
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO BE VERY
QUIET ABOUT THE WAY HE IS FOR
THE SAKE OF MY KIDS AND HIS
REPUTATION.
I'VE TRIED TO KEEP THE WAY HE
ACTS UNDER WRAPS FOR A LONG
TIME.
TODAY, HE CROSSED THE LINE.
THAT IS WHAT IS GOING ON HERE.
HE'S A GREAT ACTOR.
HE IS PHENOMENAL AT PUTTING ON A
REALLY GOOD SHOW.
>> IN 2016 THE MEDIA MOB GOES
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, WITH A PHONY
DOSSIER.
AND 2020 THEY GO ALL IN HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAPTOP IS ALL RUSSIAN
MISINFORMATION.
THEY HAVE NO INFORMATION
REPORTING OR INVESTIGATING THE
STORY ABOUT RAPHAEL WARNOCK
BECAUSE HE'S A DEMOCRAT.
NATURALLY THEY ARE PROTECTING
HIM NO MATTER WHAT AND USE
ANYTHING THEY'VE GOT AGAINST
HERSCHEL WALKER.
IT SHOULD BE FAIR BOTH WAYS,
SHOULDN'T IT?
IT'S NOT JUST WARNOCK'S PERSONAL
LIFE.
MANY OF HIS POLICIES AND BELIEFS
ARE EXTREME AND REPREHENSIBLE
AND OUT OF TOUCH WITH THE PERSON
OF GEORGIA.
WARNOCK SUPPORTS DEFUND THE
POLICE MOVEMENT.
HE REFERRED TO POLICE AS THUGS
AND GANGSTERS.
HE ONCE COMPARED THE 2016
ELECTION TO THE 9/11 TERROR
ATTACKS.
HE WANTS TO END THE PRODUCTION
OF FOSSIL FUELS, ELIMINATE THE
FILIBUSTER.
HE WENT FOR THE TRIFECTA
PRAISING LOUIS FARRAKHAN,
JEREMIAH WRIGHT AND FIDEL
CASTRO.
HE WANTS CRITICAL RACE THEORY
TAUGHT IN PUBLIC SCHOOLS AND
SENATOR WARNOCK ALSO DEMANDED
THAT AMERICA REPENT FOR ITS
WHITENESS.
HE CLAIMS THAT SOLDIERS CANNOT
SERVE GOD AND THE MILITARY.
FOR THE PAST TWO YEARS WARNOCK
HAS BEEN A RUBBERSTAMP FOR
BIDEN'S RADICAL AGENDA.
IF REELECTED, THAT WILL
UNDOUBTEDLY CONTINUE.
MEANWHILE WE MOVE TO THE GREAT
COMMONWEALTH OF PENNSYLVANIA.
THERE YOU HAVE THE TRUST FUND
BRAT IN A HOODIE WITH TATTOOS.
JOHN FETTERMAN IS PROBABLY THE
MOST RADICAL OF ALL DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES.
UNLIKE WARNOCK, FEDERMAN IS
NEVER HELD DOWN A REAL JOB
OUTSIDE OF BEING A MAYOR OF A
TOWN WHEN HE STARTED THAT HAD
ABOUT A POPULATION A LITTLE
UNDER 2200.
HE LEFT A LITTLE OVER 1700.
PEOPLE DIDN'T DO WELL UNDER HIS
MAYOR SHIP IF YOU WILL.
HE LIVED OFF MOMMY AND DADDY HIS
ENTIRE ADULT LIFE.
HE BOUGHT HIS FIRST HOME FOR $1
FROM HIS SISTER.
SOMEHOW NOT WORKING HE GOT MONEY
TO PURCHASE SIX OTHER
PROPERTIES.
I GUESS WE CAN ONLY ASSUME WITH
FAMILY MONEY.
ONE HAS TO FIRST WONDER IF HE
PAID TAXES ON THE INCOME.
HE FAILED TO PAY OVER $18000 IN
PROPERTY TAXES.
GET THIS.
HE WANTS TO RAISE TAXES ON THE
PEOPLE OF PENNSYLVANIA AND RUIN
THE ECONOMY OF THAT GREAT STATE
WITH A MORATORIUM ON FRACKING AN
$81 BILLION INDUSTRY.
DURING HIS FIRST JOB AS A
PART-TIME MAYOR OF A TINY
BURRELL CALLED BRADDOCK,
POPULATION UNDER 2200 AND IT
WENT DOWN TO 1700 BY THE TIME HE
LEFT.
HE MADE A NAME FOR HIMSELF BY
NOT SHOWING UP TO WORK.
REPORTEDLY SKIPPING DOZENS AND
DOZENS OF CITY COUNCIL MEETINGS.
WHILE HE WASN'T AT WORK HE DID
MANAGE TO GET INTO A LOT OF
LEGAL TROUBLE.
THE DEADBEAT MAYOR WAS ARRESTED
IN 2010 FOR TRESPASSING AT AN
OFFICE BUILDING IN PITTSBURGH.
LOOK AT YOUR SCREEN.
THAT SAME YEAR IT WAS FEDERMAN
WHO WAS CAUGHT ON CAMERA
LITERALLY VANDALIZING A LOCAL
BLACK OWNED BUSINESS IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT.
HE LATER ADMITTED TO THE ACT OF
VANDALISM BUT CLAIMED IT WAS
JUSTIFIED.
OKAY, JUSTIFIED?
>> I KNOW THEY HAVE CAMERAS OUT
FRONT.
IT WAS MY WAY OF PUTTING HIM ON
NOTICE.
IT WAS A PUBLIC WAY THAT I CHOSE
TO PUT HIM ON NOTICE.
WE ARE GOING TO SHUT YOU DOWN.
>> FORGET ABOUT THE LAW.
THAT BUSINESS NEVER CLOSED.
THREE YEARS LATER FETTERMAN WAS
AT IT AGAIN.
HE TASED AN INNOCENT
AFRICAN-AMERICAN JOGGER WITH A
SHOTGUN AND HELD HIM UNTIL THE
POLICE ARRIVE.
A FALSELY BLAME THE JOGGER FOR A
SHOOTING THAT NEVER EVEN HAPPEN.
WHILE FETTERMAN WAS NEVER
CHARGED HE LIKELY COMMITTED A
SERIES OF SERIOUS CRIMES
INCLUDING FALSE IMPRISONMENT.
HE EVEN ADMITTED ON TAPE IN A
NEWS INTERVIEW THAT HE LIKELY
COMMITTED A CRIME.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> I BELIEVE I DID THE RIGHT
THING BUT I MAY HAVE BROKEN THE
LAW DURING THE COURSE OF IT.
I AM CERTAINLY NOT ABOVE THE LAW
IF I DID.
>> OBVIOUSLY HE IS ABOVE THE
LAW.
IMAGINE FOR A SECOND IF IT WAS A
REPUBLICAN THAT CHASED AN
INNOCENT MINORITY DOWN THE
STREETS AND STUFFED A SHOTGUN IN
THEIR FACE AND HELD THEM
PRISONER UNTIL THE COPS CAME?
WHAT DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA
WOULD DO IN TERMS OF THE
COVERAGE OF THAT?
OF COURSE FETTERMAN DOESN'T SEEM
TO BELIEVE IN PRISON.
HE WANTS TO REDUCE THE PRISON
POPULATION IN PENNSYLVANIA BY A
WHOPPING ONE THIRD.
HE SUPPORTS ENDING LIFE
SENTENCES FOR HARD-CORE
MURDERERS.
IF SUCCESSFUL, FETTERMAN WILL
PUT VIOLENT FIRST AND SECOND
DEGREE MURDERERS BACK ON THE
STREET.
AS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR HE VOTED
TO FREEZE MULTIPLE VIOLENT
FELONS INCLUDING ONE GANG MEMBER
WHO VICIOUSLY MURDERED A HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENT BY BEATING HIM
WITH A BASEBALL BAT AND THEN
SHOOTING HIM IN THE BACK.
FETTERMAN WANTED TO PUT THAT
MURDERER BACK ON THE STREETS
BECAUSE HE BELIEVED THE
CONVICTED KILLER HAD
REHABILITATED HIMSELF IN PRISON.
THAT'S NOT THE ONLY MURDERER
FETTERMAN HAS VOTED TO SET FREE.
TAKE A LOOK FOR YOURSELF.
>> NEWS REPORT SO HE SHOT AND
KILLED A TEENAGER IN COLD BLOOD
FOR MONEY TO BUY HEROIN.
AGAINST THE CONCERNS OF THE
VICTIMS FAMILY, JOHN FETTERMAN
VOTED TO SET HIM FREE.
AS CRIME RAGES, JOHN FETTERMAN
WANTS TO TAKE HIS RADICAL VOTING
RECORD TO THE SENATE.
PENNSYLVANIA CANNOT AFFORD
FETTERMAN.
>> IF ELECTED TO THE U.S. SENATE
FETTERMAN WILL DO ANYTHING AND
EVERYTHING IN HIS POWER TO MAKE
YOU AND YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD LESS
SAFE.
NOT ONLY DOES HE WANT TO FREE
VIOLENT FELONS AND MURDERERS,
BUT HE SUPPORTS LEGALIZATION OF
HARD DRUGS LIKE HEROIN AND
OTHERS.
HE WANTS TAXPAYER-FUNDED FOR ALL
OF YOU IN PENNSYLVANIA.
HE WANT YOU TO PAY FOR SAVE
SHOOTING ZONES FOR HARD DRUGS.
FETTERMAN BELIEVES IN OPEN
BORDERS.
HE WANTS PENNSYLVANIA TO BE A
SANCTUARY STATE.
HE WANTS TO PHASE OUT ALL FOSSIL
FUELS.
HE WILL BAN FRACKING THAT WILL
DESTROY PENNSYLVANIA'S ECONOMY.
LIKE MOST OF THE DEMOCRATS HE
WANTS TO ELIMINATE THE
FILIBUSTER.
WHILE FETTERMAN WANTS VIOLENT
FELONS RUNNING FREE HE IS BOWING
TO LOCKUP BUSINESS OWNERS AND
ENERGY COMPANY CEOS THAT HE
DOESN'T LIKE.
THAT'S A PRETTY TWISTED WAY OF
THINKING ABOUT CRIMINAL JUSTICE.
THE TRUST FUND BRAT IN A HOODIE
WITH TATTOOS ALSO STATED THAT HE
DOESN'T WANT ANY SUPPORT FROM
ANYONE WHO VOTED FOR TRUMP OR
HOLDS OPPOSING BELIEFS.
MAKE NO MISTAKE, PENNSYLVANIA.
SPREAD THE WORD.
MAKE SURE EVERY PENNSYLVANIAN
KNOWS THIS GUYS RECORD.
IF YOU WANT TO VOTE FOR THEM,
HAVE AT IT.
YOU GET THE GOVERNMENT YOU
DESERVE.
JOHN IS A RUN-OF-THE-MILL
RADICAL SOCIALIST.
HE IS TO THE LEFT OF BERNIE
SANDERS.
HE ENDORSED BERNIE SANDERS.
FOLLOWING A SERIOUS STROKE HE
WILL NOT RELEASE HIS MEDICAL
RECORDS.
FETTERMAN IS UNABLE TO
COMMUNICATE OR CAMPAIGN
EFFECTIVELY.
SO FAR HE HAS BEEN UNABLE TO
ATTEND A DEBATE WITH DOCTOR OZ
OR ANSWER ONE SINGLE QUESTION
FROM THE MEDIA.
IT WAS HE HIMSELF IN THE PRIMARY
THAT TOLD VOTERS THAT THEY
DESERVE TO SEE AT LEAST THREE
DEBATES.
HE SAID, LIKE I HAVE ALWAYS
SAID, DEBATES ARE AN IMPORTANT
PART OF THE PRIMARY AND WE
BELIEVE VOTERS DESERVE NO FEWER
THAN THREE NETWORK TELEVISED
DEBATES INCLUDING ALL CANDIDATES
WHO MAKE THE BALLOT BEFORE MAJOR
MEDIA MARKETS ALL ACROSS
PENNSYLVANIA.
NOW HE WANTS NOT ONLY A DEBATE
THE WEEK BEFORE THE LAST WEEK IN
OCTOBER.
THAT'S THE ONLY ONE HE AGREED
TO.
HE WANTS CLOSED CAPTIONING AND A
TELEPROMPTER.
ASK YOURSELF, EVEN IF YOU AGREE
WITH FETTERMAN'S EXTREME
DANGEROUS POLICIES DO YOU
BELIEVE HE IS MENTALLY FIT T